let's do one more example dealing with
displacement velocity and time so we
have if Marcia travels for one minute
at five meters per second to the south
how much will she be displaced and so we
know we know that that velocity let me
do it this way we know that velocity is
equal to displacement is equal to
displacement divided by time and it's
really once again it is change in time
but we'll just say time that's
implicitly change in time and if you
manipulate this a little bit you really
just multiply both sides by time you
just multiply both sides by the variable
t you get displacement because this
cancels out you get displacement and
I'll flip this around I'll write what's
on the rights and what's on the right
hand side all right on the left so you
get displacement is equal to time times
velocity or velocity times time is equal
to velocity is equal to velocity times
time or velocity times change in time so
over here they're asking us for
displacement they're asking us how much
did Marcia get displaced and they're
saying that she travels for one minute
so this one minute right over here this
is her time sometimes you could view
that as her change in time or it really
is her change in time whatever you know
if it said if it's at zero minutes on
her stopwatch when she started at the
end it'll say one minute or if it
started said five minutes it maybe was
3:05 when she started it would be 306
when she finished it was really the
change in time once again I won't write
the Delta there just because it keeps it
this is the way you you'd off you've
most frequently see it but I want to
tell you that these are the same thing
for the purpose of this problem because
sometimes you'll see the Delta there so
the one minute so the T right over here
is one minute one minute at five meters
per second to the south at five meters
per second to the south this right over
here is the velocity they give us the
magnitude which is five meters per
second or you could say that's the speed
and they also give us the direction to
the south so this right over here
is five meters per second to to the
south so we might just say look hey if
we want displacement that's just going
to be equal to that's just going to be
equal to five meters per second to the
south to the South times one minute
times one minute times one minute the
problem here is is that when we're
talking about displacement we're going
to think about a magnitude of how much
it's moved so it'll be a distance of
some kind and some direction we have our
direction here but we don't want any
other units there and if we just
multiply this over here we have a minute
over here but we have seconds in the
denominator you can't just cancel out a
minute in a second so you can't just say
you're going to get five and have some
weird thing here so in order for it to
all work out you have to either convert
the five meters permit per second to
five meters per minute or not or let me
phrase that another way you have to
convert the five meters per second to
some amount of meters per minute not
five meters per minutes going to be
different or you convert the one minute
to seconds so at least in my mind it's
easier to convert one minute to seconds
so let's do that so this is the same
thing one minute times and we want to
get rid of the minute and the minute is
essentially in the numerator right now
we could put this over one but it's
essentially the numerator so we want to
divide by minutes we want to divide by
minute and we want to multiply by
seconds we want seconds in the numerator
and so what is how many seconds are
there per minute you have 60 seconds for
every for every one minute and so you
have a minute
cancelling out with the minutes and so
now you have five meters per second to
the south times 60 seconds this is now
cool because you have seconds and
seconds I wrote SEC there but this is
also SEC so now you have seconds seconds
over seconds those cancel out and so
your displacement is going to be equal
to five times sixty five times 60 and
then your units left are meters all the
all the time units have cancelled out
and then it's meters to the south so me
ders to the to the south and this is
equal to this is equal to five times 60
is 300 meters to to the south and we are
done that's how much she has been
displaced if they just wanted the
distance you could say that she traveled
you could say that she traveled 300
meters just that part the magnitude of
the displacement that is that is the
distance that she traveled